what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so making this video I am going to treat
the person watching it as if they've
never really read DC in their life and I
think it makes things a lot easier for
people who are new to comic books
because this is really geared more
towards new fans as opposed to existing
fans but if you are an existing fan and
you know feel free to watch it I'd
prefer you to leave but you know I
really wanted to sort of offer this a
little bit of a fear here at the very
least try to answer questions or try to
come to our own conclusions you know
basically on what's going on with the
watchmen and the DC Universe because
Doomsday Clock is right around the
corner for those of you guys who don't
know the Doomsday Clock is going to be a
12 issue story that comes out in
Thanksgiving I think it is that's
basically going to have like the
watchman's big reveal in DC rebirth
because right now there is kind of
clandestine there behind the scenes we
don't really even know what's going on
now for the most part I usually try to
avoid you know spoilers other people's
theories different things like that
because I don't want to sort of combine
them with my own but at this point you
know really in the history of DC Reaver
there's really no way to offer a theory
that hasn't been done before but there
are some videos from YouTube actually
that we're really kind of cool the for
example the fortress of solitude YouTube
channel has a really cool video called
watching The Watchmen a DC rebirth guide
there is super kind of guru this done
videos hybrid Network has done videos a
lot of people have done videos based on
Watchmen of course you'll find those
YouTube channels down in the description
but for those of you guys who are new
the reason why the Watchmen is such a
big deal is because it's really what the
Watchmen have done that have changed
everything most people who read DC
Comics right now who are reading in the
modern day most likely picked up in the
1990s you know they got into DC comics
because of the Teen Titans TV show where
they got in because of the Justice
League cartoon show or whatever whatever
the case may be but most people started
reading in the 1990s there aren't very
many at least you know as far as I'm
aware who are still reading to read back
in like you know we're reading before
1985 I'm sure there's some large but
nonetheless the Watchmen are in this
idea where it's essentially that dr.
Manhattan this godlike being had
basically gone through and modified the
DC Universe and made it the way it is
right now so to whine us back a little
bit um back before 2011 DC basically had
three styles of comics that they were
publishing you had the superhero comics
that you think of when you think of like
Batman Wonder Woman Superman the flash
that kind of
that's their superhero landscape the
second type is their adult-oriented
stuff so like angels demon Satan
that's all vertigo that's where you find
like John Constantine and things like
that
the third type is Wildstorm and that's a
company that was published in August it
was established back in 1992 by a guy
named Jim Lee who is a writer and artist
found his claim to fame in the 1990s
x-men comics but eventually Wildstorm
was essentially acquired by DC and then
their characters of the sort of world in
but they were oft to decide the year or
two leading up to 2011 DC launched a
story called flashpoint and what
flashpoint was designed to do was
basically just consolidate all of DCs
superheroes so instead of having these
three different types of comics they
would all just be one type of comic and
the idea is that you would have you know
the angels and demons you know mysticism
and sorcery and the vertigo comics
crossing over with the superhero comics
of Batman Superman Wonder Woman as well
as the wild storm comics of Gimli
now the way in which DC did this through
flashpoint it's basically about having
Barry Allen run back and forth your time
and screw things up now we've covered
flashpoint so we don't really need to go
to in-depth into that you'll find that
video down in the description it's
pretty important if you want to
understand why we're where we're at
right now with regards to DC rebirth but
the idea here is that before the events
of Flashpoint DC had a huge rich history
you had like the death of Superman you
had Batman having his back broken by
Bane during the events of nightfall you
had Hal Jordan the Green Lantern
becoming a bad guy during the events of
Emerald Twilight and almost obliterating
the entirety of the DC Universe you had
stories like Infinite Crisis you had
characters like Superboy Ron you had all
this stuff that DC had built up and a
lot of fans absolutely loved it DC
wanted to eliminate all that and they
wanted to reboot now the nature of a
reboot is essentially when a comic book
publisher comes along and they say okay
we're starting from square one in the
case of DC when they rebooted with the
new 52 what they were doing is they were
saying we want you as a person who's
never read comics before we want you to
imagine that we've never published
anything about Superman that actually
comics number one from the new 52 that
Superman number one from the new 52 this
is the first time we've ever published
anything about his character he gets a
new origin story his characters are
changed all that kind of good stuff is
the jumping on point so that you don't
have to worry about not understanding
what's going on you basically learn
about
man's new history as it goes along and
so you're effectively an expert so long
as you've been reading since issue
number one and it worked for the most
part because you know the beauty to run
only lasted 52 issues for each
individual character so this whole idea
by bringing in this new 52 reboot came
by way of very Alan messing with time
very on the flash kind of screwing
things up and then when it was all said
and done the wild storm at the Vertigo
and the main DC superheroes all just
merged into one great big huge universe
the reason why this is important is
because DC Weaver basically came back
and it fixed all the things that people
didn't like about the original new 52
launch which is to say characters who
had been eliminated
in their entirety the classic red haired
Wally West for example was replaced with
the young african-american Wally West
different stories like that man having
his back broken by Bane never happened
store Lisa didn't happen initially
stories like The Death of Superman never
happened those are things that people
wanted to see kept intact but ultimately
they weren't because everything was
effectively rebooted what DC is dealing
with the Watchmen is they're coming
along and they're saying okay the
original timeline went like this DC had
all their superheroes and they had all
their stories very Allen screwed up time
and he basically consolidated all the
universes into one and then created one
great big huge new universe called the
new 52 but what actually happened is
that dr. Manhattan of the Watchmen
suddenly stepped in in the time when
this new universe was being created or
what have you and so where Barry Allen
was done and things were supposed to go
back to the way they were before
dr. Manhattan made it so that things
changed that's basically what they're
saying the entire landscape of the DC
universe as it exists right now with the
new 52 that's not because of Barry Allen
that's because of dr. Manhattan now the
question is why and that's the answer
that we don't have that's what we're
trying to figure out that's what we're
waiting on until the events of Doomsday
Clock
but dr. Manhattan historically has
always been sort of an interesting
character he's always been this sort of
guy who was more intrigued by people but
also disconnected from humanity and so
the idea is that if a person doesn't
really care whether or not people live
and die then of what use would altering
a universe be to dr. Manhattan and the
only alternative that we can come to the
only conclusion that I can think of is
that somebody else got dr. Manhattan to
do it somebody else basically went to
dr. Manhattan and said
a you should change this you should make
this universe better the result is that
we got everything that it is right now
so the question is who was it that made
dr. Manhattan do this or asked him to do
it if anybody did at all my thought is
that it's Lex Luthor and this is kind of
the cool thing about this because this
was an idea that was initially put
forward by Sal over common pop we were
on the weekly full podcast one day and
we were talking about all these theories
about who it is that mr. Oz might be
this clandestine guy in the green cloak
who hasn't revealed his identity and is
secretly been watching sometimes helping
sometimes hindering other superheroes he
doesn't really ally himself to any one
particular cause he's just kind of there
as this enigma taking different you know
superheroes prisoner so over a cupboard
pop put forward the idea that mr. Oz is
actually Lex Luthor
another question is why if this is
classic Lex Luthor from before the new
52 when Lex Luthor was the traditional
bad guy the Lex Luthor that you think of
when you think of Superman's arch
nemesis the question would be why we
don't know I have no earthly clue I
can't even begin to answer that question
the most likely character to be mr. Oz
is Ozymandias but I figure like that's
that's too obvious I figured that him
being Ozymandias is just too easy of a
goal is too easy as an idea but maybe
DC's making on that maybe DC is looking
at us and saying okay so the fan base is
going to see mr. Oz and they're going to
say well that's obviously mr. Ozymandias
but then they're going to question
themselves and say but that's too easy
of a guess so they're going to make it
mr. Oz so that way it turns out to be
the character that we thought it was all
along we just didn't really think it was
but even if that is Ozymandias even if
that is like solutely or whatever the
case may be there's other members of the
Watchmen group that we don't know where
they're at one of the most notable here
would be like night owl he's so expector
somebody else you know could be that war
Shaq came back to life it could be that
the comedian was resurrected and we
don't really know if he is the button
that you see in DC rebirth that's the
button of the comedian it still has
blood on it which indicates that the
comedian still dead that's where that
blood drop came from when the comedian
was killed during the events of the
original Watchmen story which we'll
cover but there's a lot of questions out
there there's a lot of things to sort of
engage in out here and a lot of ideas to
put forward and so my general theory is
this dr. Manhattan mess with Todd dr.
Manhattan basically adjusted the
universe so that instead of Barry Allen
going through screwing up time and in
things going back to the way they were
supposed to be that instead this new
universe gets created dr. Manhattan did
that because somebody told him to dr.
Manhattan did that because somebody got
him to whether it was Ozymandias Lex
Luthor whatever the case may be I think
the other members of the Watchmen I
think night owl I think Silk Spectre
I think these other members of the
Watchmen even Ozymandias himself are
basically going through and they're
biting their tongue they're watching the
superheroes I think ultimately we'll see
them ally with the superheroes against
dr. Manhattan and whoever it is that dr.
Manhattan is working alongside this
isn't a theory that I have any absolute
fact for I don't have any absolute basis
for it there's all kinds of different
theories out there for example there are
people who are saying that the Joker is
actually the comedian I don't
necessarily think that's true I think
the three Joker's are just Joker's from
three different eras of Batman's history
I think one is the original Joker from
the Golden Age I think one is the Joker
from The Killing Joke and I think one is
the new 52 just different universes
different eras different time periods
all of whom are going to consolidate in
one singular location but the vet
remains I think the other Watchmen are
there they're just kind of biding their
time they're watching things unfold and
I think that they are actually allies of
superheroes waiting to see what the
superheroes are about waiting to see who
they are
maybe the Watchmen don't know they're
Watchmen because remember when it came
to characters like Jay Garrick to flash
when it came to like Johnny Thunder
different things like that from the
old-school Justice Society of America
the predecessors to the Justice League
for the 1930s and 1940s the idea was
that they basically did vanish you know
they disappeared nobody knew they were
gone
nobody had any idea that they weren't
there and so it could very well be that
like The Watchmen that we think of night
owl Silk Spectre you know maybe even war
shock if he's still back the idea could
be that they don't know who they are
they have no idea that they're members
of The Watchmen they don't know their
past their minds have been white
whatever the case may be we saw in DC
Universe rebirth number one but the
classic Wally West was able to make his
return because he encountered Barry
Allen Barry Allen remembered him and
that basically allowed theory to pull
the classic Wally West out of a Speed
Force and basically bring him back to
life
effectively resurrect him when it came
to thee when it comes to the other
members of the Watchmen maybe that's
what it will be
maybe that's it'll it'll come to this
realization that the flash will just run
around and start waking them up
quote-unquote to who it is they're
supposed to be and then we'll get this
huge explanation on what it is that's
going on what dr. Manhattan did we'll
get the backside of the events during
this whole flashpoint conversion to the
new 52 from their perspective we'll get
the other side of the story that we were
never told
so again it'd be kind of cool you know
to see how all that unfolds but this is
just my little theory just sort of
tossing my thoughts out there I thought
it'd be a fun little video if you guys
are new here to comment explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob port you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Applause]